[Music]
San Francisco which in recent years has
become a complete garbage heat San
Francisco which is now riddled with on
the streets human excrement and people
lying out dying potentially of exposure
shooting up dying of overdoses when
they're not dying of exposure just crime
and filth filling the city people
fleeing what was once one of the most
beautiful cities in the country Nome
cleaned it all up they cleaned up we
have before pictures we got after
pictures in San Francisco and just look
wow the s are gone the trash is gone the
bums have been shuffled
off it's all it's all better how did
they do that well it's all gone because
xiin ping is coming to San Francisco all
it took to clean up one of America's
once great cities was for a Chinese
Communist dictator come visit and then
the Civil Authority decides they're
going to clean it up